Let's get our feet wet and apply this
concept to an app mock screen by making
it more material with some surfaces.
The goal of this app,
Walk In, was to replace those
buzzers you receive at restaurants.
Instead of sticking within a short
range, you could scan a QR code,
get on the list, then go off and
do whatever you wanted until you were
notified that your table is ready.
It was one of those apps
I developed back in 2011.
You can call it a bit vintage,
back when Android specific
design hadn't taken off yet.
So how will we use surfaces to
make this screen more material?
The image and
the restaurant information are related
so they should be on their own surface.
The items in the queue are also related,
that's another surface.
The last surface is
the button bar down here.
It'll be replaced for other reasons,
but for the purpose of this exercise,
it also should be a surface.